let's get right to the heart of the
matter our company has suffered serious
damage both to productivity and human
relations
organizations that are able to adapt or
most able to survive Design Thinking is
a way of interacting with your consumer
to define a problem based on their
emotional needs and then rapidly
prototyping and rapidly iterating to a
final solution what we teach is an
intuition and practice around adapting
to change I love the fact that we got
classroom instruction and case studies
how other organizations have implemented
innovation frameworks it's a wonderful
pairing of academic rigor with hands-on
relevance this is a chance for
participants to both think deeply about
what it means to drive organic growth
and to feel viscerally what it takes to
engage in these approaches one of the
big things we teach our executives is
how to embrace diversity of opinion
using a common process design this is a
perfect framework for my company I don't
use it exactly the way that it was
taught but I use it in a way that works
for my environment what I took away was
how to take design thinking and actually
put it in to play at my organization
you're in the epicenter of innovation
here at Stanford you have people doing
thinking and talking about ways of
driving innovation all around you from
the moment you hit the ground here until
the moment you leave you're not gonna
stop moving and from the moment you
leave you're not gonna stop thinking
about what you learned the energy of
this place is infectious this is an
inspiration style when I went back to my
company I was on fire I was so excited
to take what I learned and bring it back
and make meaningful change learning
Design Thinking was not only a career
changing experience but very much a life
changing experience for me can we get a
gong here
that's a wrap